hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live Bayerns Vize Regierungschef
Aiwanger Hubert Aiwanger muss sich
dringend erklären für das antisemitische
flugblattwasser in der Tasche hatte er
hat ein Statement angekündigt was er
jetzt in Bayern gibt wir schalten live
drauf und danach für euch analysieren
wir diese Rede
wir sehen uns schon
ja guten Tag
von Staatsminister Hubert einwanger zu
den aktuellen
wir bitten um Verständnis dass Fragen
heute nicht zugelassen sind ergänzen zu
der Erklärung darf ich Ihnen ankündigen
dass der Staatsminister den
Fragenkatalog der Staatsregierung der
Staatskanzlei zeitnah beantworten wird
in den vergangenen Tagen hat es
zahlreiche Vorwürfe gegen mich gegeben
es geht um ein abscheuliches Pamphlet
das vor 36 Jahren in meiner Schultasche
gefunden wurde und es sind Aussagen
aufgetaucht die den Eindruck vermitteln
ich werde es Jugendlicher auf einen
menschenfeindlichen Weg geraten ich habe
als jugendlich auch Fehler gemacht ich
bereue zutiefst wenn ich durch mein
Verhalten in Bezug auf das in Rede
stehende Pamphlet oder weitere Vorwürfe
gegen mich aus der Jugendzeit Gefühle
verletzt habe meine aufrichtige
Entschuldigung gilt zuvor dass da ein
Opfern des Ines Regimes deren
Hinterbliebenen und allen Beteiligten
und der wertvollen Erinnerungsarbeit
die genannten Vorwürfe liegen 36 Jahre
zurück ich betone nochmals ich habe das
beim Fleet nicht verfasst nicht
distanziere mich in jeder Form von dem
ekelhaften Inhalt ich war nie ein
Antisemit ich war nie ein
menschenvereint
die Vorwürfe haben mich erschreckt ich
kann mich nicht erinnern jemals einen
Hitlergruß gezeigt zu haben ich habe
keine Hitler reden vor dem Spiegel
einstudiert weitere Vorwürfe wie
menschenfeindliche Witze kann ich aus
meiner Erinnerung wieder vollständig
dementieren auch bestätigen sollte dies
geschehen sein so entschuldige ich mich
dafür in aller Form es ist jedoch nicht
akzeptabel dass diese Verfehlungen jetzt
in einer politischen Kampagne gegen mich
und meine parteiinstrumentalisiert
werden ich habe den Eindruck ich soll
politisch und persönlich fertig gemacht
werden es ist ein negatives Bild von mir
in den letzten Tagen gezeichnet worden
das bin nicht ich das ist nicht Hubert
vielen Dank
danke schön
ich bin wieder da
ein sehr kurzes ein abgelesenes
Statement von Hubert Aiwanger und wir
können darüber jetzt sprechen mit
unserem Korrespondenten in München
wir können jetzt darüber sprechen so das
war das kurze Statement von sehr kurzes
Statement von Hubert Aiwanger ein
abgelesenes Statement eine
Entschuldigung die er abgegeben hat über
die können wir jetzt sprechen wir können
das ganze jetzt einordnen mit unserem
Korrespondenten in München Stefan
leifert ist mir zugeschaltet hallo
Stefan Du bist live vor Ort hallo
gehört ist dürfen keine Fragen gestellt
werden keine Fragen von dir von anderen
Journalisten es wurde ein sehr kurzes
Statement verlesen es wurde außerdem
gesagt der Fragenkatalog der Hubert
Aiwanger aufgegeben worden ist von
Regierungschef Söder der werde zeitnah
beantwortet das heißt es schon seit
Dienstag dass das passieren soll und
jetzt haben wir ihn also gehört mit
einigen Sätzen er entschuldigte sich bei
Opfern des NS-Regimes und vor allem
sagte er zu den Vorwürfen zu einigen der
Vorwürfen er könne sich nicht erinnern
kannst du das Ganze für uns einschätzen
was das jetzt heute für eine Aktion war
was er damit erreichen möchte
das war's Hubert Aiwanger hier gerade
versucht hat war ein Befreiungsschlag er
hat das geliefert was viele von ihnen
schon seit Tagen eingefordert haben
nämlich mehr als ein immer nur
scheibchenweise zugeben oder abstreiten
von Vorwürfen das was er hier versucht
hat das ist die große Entschuldigung und
eine Geste der Reue es ist eine neue
Tonlage die Hubert Aiwanger hier
eingezogen hat nämlich die von
Entschuldigung und Tiefen Bedauern
Robert einfacher hat noch einmal was er
gestern in einem Interview auch schon
betont hat gesagt er sei kein Antisemit
und sei es auch nie gewesen sollte es
einzelne Vorfälle gegeben haben an die
er sich nicht erinnern kann die aber
möglicherweise die Gefühle von
opferndes in es Regimes z.B verletzt
haben sollten dann entschuldige er sich
hierfür zu tiefst das ist natürlich noch
nicht die Antwort auf die 25 Fragen des
Fragenkatalogs der Hubert einfach
inzwischen auch vorliegt sondern es ist
vor allem der Versuch einer Geste für
die Öffentlichkeit in seine eigene
Partei hinein und drittens auch in CSU
Markus Söder hat ja vor zwei Tagen sehr
deutlich gemacht dass das ganze was
Hubert Aiwanger vorgeworfen wird keine
jungen Streich ist nicht als Jugendsünde
einfach abzutun ist das hat Robert
Aiwanger bis jetzt ja versucht und von
der Linie schwenkt er jetzt ein wenig ab
und versucht hier heute eine große Geste
von Bedauern und Reue zu setzen das ist
ein neuer Ton ob es rechtzeitig kommt
das ist eine andere Frage die nächsten
Tage werden jetzt davon geprägt sein auf
den Fragenkatalog zu warten wo eine
Reihe von sehr ausdifferenzierten Fragen
drin stehen da geht es um seine Rolle
damals beim Verfassen des Flugblattes da
hat er gerade noch einmal betont das sei
er nicht gewesen dass er sein Bruder
gewesen und um viele andere Vorwürfe die
in den letzten Tagen noch mal
untermauert oder neu hinzugefügt worden
sind von Mitschülern die sich daran von
damals noch erinnern können das ist
gerade angesprochen eine Scheibchen
Taktik genannt wie er sich in den
letzten Tagen geäußert hat zunächst
samstags zunächst schriftlich hat er
genau das gesagt er sei nicht der
Verfasser aber er hatte trotzdem
eingeräumt er hatte das Schreiben in der
Brief in der Schultasche dann plötzlich
da tauchte der Bruder auf als der Vater
er Verfasser hat sich da geäußert und
gestern gab es auch schon mal ein kurzes
Statement von Hubert einwanger wir hören
mal kurz rein dass er gestern gesagt hat
ich bin weder Antisemit noch Extremist
sondern ich bin ein Demokrat ich bin ein
Menschenfreund kein Menschen Feind und
in sofern sage ich das wirklich dass ich
hier für die letzten Jahrzehnte alle
Hände ins Feuer legen kann und wo sie in
Jugendzeiten hier diskutiert wird
wundert mich etwas aber es ist auf alle
Fälle so dass vielleicht in der
Jugendseite seine oder andere so oder so
interpretiert werden kann wo soll es
15-Jähriger hier mir vorgeworfen wird
aber auf alle Fälle ich sage seitdem
Erwachsenenalter die letzten Jahrzehnte
keine Antisemit keine Extremist sondern
ein Menschenfreund
für diese Aussage im Erwachsenenalter
kein Antisemit gab es viel Kritik online
bei Twitter heute jetzt genannt Ex
insbesondere da konnte sich viel Kritik
darüber lesen diese
Kommunikationsstrategie die da gefahren
wurde in den letzten Tagen jetzt auch
heute nur dieses kurzes Statement keine
Journalisten fragen wie ist das von Dir
zu bewerten tut er sich damit
eingefallen jetzt gerade in diesem
heißen Wahlkampf dieser heißen Phase des
Wahlkampf in Bayern
also mit dem was er in den letzten Tagen
kommuniziert hat hat er sich sicherlich
keinen Gefallen getan viele in der CSU
also beim Koalitionspartner haben sich
die Frage gestellt ob Hubert Aiwanger
eigentlich Kommunikationsberater hat
oder irgendwie Leute in seine Umfeld hat
die ihn da beraten können heute das war
jetzt zum ersten Mal eine Tonlage die er
vielleicht schon früher hätte anschlagen
können um glaubhaft zu machen dass er
die Vorwürfe wirklich ernst nimmt dieser
Fall hat ja zwei Ebenen das eine ist die
Ebene der Ereignisse von damals also in
im Jugendalter von Hubert Aiwanger vor
über 35 Jahren und die zweite Ebene ist
der Umgang mit diesen Vorwürfen bisher
hatte man nicht den Eindruck das Hubert
Aiwanger die Vorwürfe für die da im Raum
stehen wirklich ernst nimmt das sind ja
schwerwiegende Vorwürfe Antisemitismus
das ist der Herbst den man einem
deutschen Politiker machen kann und die
letzten Tage waren nicht davon geprägt
dass man den Eindruck hatte Hubert
einfach er nimmt das wirklich ernst das
hat er versucht mit der Erklärung von
heute ein wenig umzudrehen es war von
tiefer Reue von tiefen bedauern Rede
eine Entschuldigung bei Leuten deren
Gefühle er möglicherweise verletzt hat
also das ist eine neue Tonlage die Frage
ist ob es rechtzeitig kommt und ob es
angesichts des späten Zeitpunkts jetzt
noch wirklich glaubhaft ist diese Frage
geht ja in zwei Richtungen das eine ist
die breite Öffentlichkeit und das andere
ist vor allem aber die Frage des
Koalitionspartners Markus Söder hat ja
einen Fragenkatalog eben mit auf den Weg
gegeben mit 25 sehr ausdifferenzierten
Fragen zu den Ereignissen von damals und
darauf wird es jetzt ankommen aber
sicherlich war das heute ein Vorspiel
was darauf hindeutet dass er das was da
in diesem Fragenkatalog Anfragen
aufgeführt ist jedenfalls sehr ernst
nimmt schauen wir auch eben noch mal in
die Zukunft am 8 Oktober wird bei euch
in Bayern gewählt also das ist natürlich
jetzt für Markus Söder auch ein sehr
ungünstiger Zeitpunkt wird das selbst
genannt er braucht also Antworten er
braucht diese Antworten von seinem Vize
Regierungschefs von den Freien Wählern
seinem Koalitionspartner wir hatten am
Dienstag auch live streamt da hatte sich
ja Markus Söder geäuß ert forderte also
ein diese schriftliche Beantwortung der
Fragen wie schätzt du das ein Stefan
jetzt also aus der aus der Sicht von
Markus Söder der jetzt im Wahlkampf mit
einem Wahlkampf steckt und sich da
eigentlich ja ganz klar zu den Freien
Wählern nach wie vor committed hat als
den Koalitionspartner richtig
ja Markus Söder hat ein sehr
differenzierte Strategie gefahren er
will an den Freien Wählern als
Koalitionspartner festhalten ein
bisschen auch aus Not natürlich weil das
für ihn jetzt ein sehr sehr weiter und
schwieriger Weg wäre auf die Grünen auf
die SPD oder auf die FDP zuzugehen zum
anderen versucht er aber auch die
Strategie zu fahren bei den Freien
Wählern zu bleiben aber möglicherweise
auf Hubert Aiwanger als Minister zu
verzichten das ist nach wie vor eine
offene Frage denn jetzt stellt sich ja
die Frage reicht das was Hubert
einfacher hier im Moment kommuniziert
und was er auf die Fragen antworten wird
aus um Minister im Kabinett Söder zu
bleiben er ist die Gallionsfigur der
Freien Wähler schlechthin Hubert awanger
ist im Grunde die Partei und sollte die
Partei jetzt auf Hubert einfacher
verzichten müssen dann könnte das die
Inklusion der Freien Wähler als Partei
bedeuten in der CSU ging auch die Angst
um das Hubert awanger sich
möglicherweise mit einer neuen Partei
selbstständig macht all das sind
absolute Unwegbarkeiten bei denen man
überhaupt nicht absehen kann wem das
nützt wegen des schade dass es für die
CSU bedeutet
du machst jetzt in einer schwierigen
Lage denn er hat die Latte vor allem
auch moralisch sehr sehr hoch gehängt er
hat gesagt es darf überhaupt kein Rest
Zweifel bleiben an den Vorwürfen er
verlangt eine Entschuldigung er verlangt
Reue Hubert einfach eine hat den Ton
jetzt gesetzt aber das ist natürlich
noch nicht das was als Antwort auf die
vielen einzelnen Vorwürfe jetzt erwartet
wird das werden die nächsten Tage zeigen
aber sicherlich Hubert Aiwanger hat mit
der Erklärung von heute für sich
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen Zeit
gewonnen
Einschätzung von Stefan leifert jetzt
kurz für heute für diesen Moment nach
dem Statement von Hubert Albaner danke
schön
und danke auch an euch für diese kurze
Sendung eure Aufmerksamkeit wir sehen
uns wieder bis später tschüss